翻訳: Yuriya Nakagawa
校正: Mai Iida
私が医師としての人生をどうやって過ごすか
そういうものを決めさせた後景があります
それは私が東大病院で勤務医をしていた時期に
自分の患者さんの自宅に訪問する
そのような機会がありました
患者さんはこのような家の中に住んでいたんです
私はびっくりしました
今まで外来 そして入院の患者さんしか
見たことのなかった私にとっては
自分の患者さんがこんな中に住んでいるんだ
と衝撃的なことでした
だいたい一日中このように布団の上に寝て
そして近くにあるパンやジュースを飲んで
そして誰とも話さない
周りはゴミの山です
これが高齢社会の現実なんだ と
そこで色々調べてみたんです
そうしたら 私の患者さんだけが特別ではない
ということがわかりました
今から 例えば10年経ったら
世帯の４割は高齢者がいる世帯になります
そしてそのうちの７割は
高齢者が１人で住んでいたり
もしくは夫婦だけで過ごしている
そんなような社会になる
このようにわかってきたんです
こんな高齢者が
非常に孤独な状態で生きている
これをなんとかしたい
これを人生のテーマに決めたわけです
じゃあ医者として何ができるんだろう
そう思って色々考えた結果が
「在宅医療」という道でした
在宅医療というのは
例えばもう病院に通うことができない
もしくはガンの終末期で
もう最期は家で過ごしたい
そういった患者さんのお家に医師が訪問して
そこで医療やケアをする
それで何かあったら24時間駆けつけて対応する
そんなような医療だったんです
2010年1月ですね
文京区に在宅医療のクリニックを作って
そして始めた時は
「さあこれで 高齢者の孤独に対して何かできる」
そういう風に思ったんです
ところが始めてみると
とてもそんな甘いもんじゃないんです
我々が訪問して 診断をして 医療やケアをして
お薬を出したり
もしくは「こういう食事がいいですよ」
そういうお話をするわけなんですけれど
ところが 例えば認知症の方とかは
きちんとお薬が飲めない
もしくは「こういう食事がいいんですよ」と
いくら勧めても自分で作れないので
結局食べられない
一番衝撃的だったのは
私が患者さんと会った時
その時はニコニコしている
だけど帰る時には
ものすごく寂しそうな顔をしている
全然高齢者の孤立というものに関して
一人の医師としては何もできていないんだなあ
そんなように思って
「どうしたらいいだろうか」と思っていたんです
そんな時に一つの出会いがありました
それは宮城県石巻市です
東日本大震災があった後 私は
宮城県の石巻市に行って
そして ここにこそ在宅医療の
必要な人がいると思って
クリニックをもう一個建てて
そこで在宅診療を始めたんです
在宅診療をしているだけではなくて
被災者の支援もしました
そうしたらある時
一緒に活動をしているボランティアの人が
「だいぶ体の調子の悪いおじいちゃんがいるので
診に行ってくれないか」
と言われて私は行ったわけです
その患者さんは安部正吉さん(仮名)という方で
72歳の方でした
その安部正吉さんの家の周りは
すべて流されてしまっていて
正吉さんの家は ２階は大丈夫だったので
そこに住んでいたわけです
私は行って その人の診察をしようと思いましたら
「もう生きていてもしょうがない
他の人は死んでしまったのに
自分が生き残って本当に申し訳ない
だから医者なんていらないんだ」
と言って家にも入れてくれないわけです
私は帰って そして一緒に働いている
活動している人たちに
「正吉さんってどういう人なんだろう」と
聞いたわけなんです
そうしたら
例えば 「家に風がぴゅーぴゅー入って
すごく困っていた」
もしくは 「眠れなくて辛い」とか
「夜中に亡くなった友達のことを思い出している」
「泣いている」 とか
「とにかく寒いんだ あの家は」
「カビだらけだ」
そんなような情報が入ってくるわけですね
みんなで相談をして
「じゃあ何ができるんだろう」と
そして翌日には 男性のボランティアが行って
壁にすごい穴が空いていたので
そこをふさいであげたり
その次の日には
布団がカビだらけだったので
新しく布団を持って行ったり
また カウンセラーのような人が定期的に訪問して
色々な話を聞く
そんなことをやっていくうちに
ようやく何ヶ月か経って
私も医者として入ることができたんです
「震災前どんな薬を飲んでいたの」と
そして体を拝見させていただいて
「じゃあこの薬を飲みましょう」と
驚いたことに正吉さんは
どんどん元気になっていったんです
ある時「何やっているの」と聞いたら
「自転車をもらって 友達が被災しているので
その人たちのところに行って
様子を見に行ってあげてるんだ」と
そんなようなことを言っていたんです
私はここから多くのことを学びました
一つは 一人の高齢者の方がいらしたら
その人の情報をものすごくいろんな視点で
取ってこなくちゃいけない
包括的にその人の情報を取ってきて
そして何かできる人たちが集まって
その情報を分析して
それぞれできることを提供していく
こういう仕組みが必要なんじゃないかと
よくプロフェッショナルな人の
問題点っていうのはですね
自分ができることで
なんとか対応しよう と思うわけです
例えば 眠れない っていうことがあったとします
まあヤブ医者だったら 睡眠薬を出して終わり
だけど本当に問題なのは
例えば 寒くて 寒いから眠れない
ということだってあるわけです
もしくは 亡くなった人のことを思って眠れない
もしくは カビが生えている布団だから眠れないとか
そういう複合的な状況が
たくさんありますよね
そういうものを共有して
みんなで考えていく
何がその人にふさわしいやり方なんだ と
これが一つです
もう一つ わかったのは
よく高齢者っていうのは
「何かしてあげなきゃいけない
救ってあげなきゃいけない」
普通そう思うじゃないですか
だけど 正吉さんの場合で言えば
もちろん家も大変な状態になって
身体も弱ってしまった
だけど元気になったのは実は
自分が誰かのところに行って見守ってあげる
もしくは 人に頼りにされる
そういう経験 もしくは環境ができて初めて
正吉さんは元気になったわけです
じゃあこの学びを
日本が 全体がこれから
迎える超高齢社会において
どういう風にしていったらいいか
これまたすごく難しい問題です
うーん って悩んで 考えた結果
これを見て思いついたことがあるんです
これ スマートフォンです
このコンセプトを社会に適応できないか
どういうことかって言うと
このスマートフォン
まあ皆さん ほとんどの人が
持っていると思いますけども
でもこのスマートフォンにある僕のアプリと
多分皆さんのアプリって
かなりの部分で違うと思うんですよね
それはなんで違うのかというと
それは僕が必要としているサービスと
皆さんが必要としているサービスが
違うからなんですね
じゃあ高齢者の場合はどういうことが言えるだろう
それは 皆さん例えば若い人たちは
自分の思考でいろんなバリエーションってありますよね
だけど高齢者っていうことで考えると
実は身体の様子でバリエーションがある
例えばある人は目が見にくいとか
ある人は耳が聞こえにくい
もしくは認知症の程度でもバリエーションがある
置かれた生活環境の中でもバリエーションがある
だからその人が置かれたバリエーションの中で
いろんなサービスを提供しようと思ったら
たくさんのサービスを揃えなければいけない
つまり アプリをサービスに例えるのであれば
そのアプリをたくさん準備しなければいけない
ということです
じゃあたくさんあればそれで良いのか というと
それとも違うんです
その人にあったサービスを選べるような
場所がないといけないんです
それがいわゆるiPhoneみたいなもんなんです
つまりそこから自分が望むサービスを
選べるような場所を作っていかないといけない
今まで高齢者の対策っていうのは
大体行政がやったりしていたんです
もしくはNPOとか もしくは一部の企業がやろうとした
だけど皆バラバラにやっていたから
一つのプラットフォームの上でやっているということは
ほとんどなかったんです
じゃあそれで足りるのかというと
実はそれだけでは足りないんですね
なんでかって言うと高齢者の人たちは
自分が必要なサービスを理解できるかって言うと
理解できない人もいるわけです
だから誰かが
「あなたに必要なサービスはこれなんですよ」
というのを教えてあげる 勧めてあげないといけない
それで 高齢者っていうのは
どんどんどんどん歳を重ねていくと
認知機能とか身体機能とか
変わっていきますよね
だから必要なサービスも変わってくる
多くの情報が集まって
そしてそれを分析すれば
次に必要となるサービスって予測できますよね
例えば皆さんがAmazonからメールが来て
「次にこういう本が出ます 買いませんか？」
というオファーが来ることってあるじゃないですか
ああいう感じなわけですよ
つまり例えば 歩行スピードが落ちてきた人がいたら
次は転倒する危険性が高いかもしれない
だったらこういう道具があったほうがいいよね とか
こういうサービスがあったら転倒を
予防することができるかもしれない とか
いろんな情報が集まってくると
次の近い未来を予測できる
したがって 重症化することも防げるかもしれない
こんなようなことが言えるわけです
もう一つは アプリ同士で情報共有って
今なされているじゃないですか
例えばFacebookとGoogleの間で
いろいろな情報が共有されているので
二重入力をする必要がない とか
そんなことって ありますよね
こちらのプラットフォームでも
この概念ってのはすごく大事なんです
例えば 軽い脳梗塞にかかって
体が動きにくくなった
そういう情報が入ったら
次に来る食事が
例えば食べやすいものに変わっているとか
もしくはリハビリのメニューが変わるとか
外に出て行くときに サポートする体制が変わるとか
そういった情報共有をすると
すぐに その人の変化に合わせて
ありとあらゆるサービスのネットワークが
変わるということができるかもしれない
もう一つは このプラットフォーム
この中で新しいコミュニティが生まれるかもしれない
今の高齢者のコミュニティっていうのは
基本的に地縁なわけですね 地域の
だけれども 例えば
「私はこういうサービスを使っている」とか
「自分はこういうものが好きなんだ」とか
その中で新しいコミュニティが
生まれるかもしれないわけです
もっと大事なのは
例えば「私はこの時間だったら今までの経験とか
知識とかスキルを使って
他の人のためにも何かできるかもしれない」
そういう情報がマッチングできれば
互いに支え合う
つまり自分はサービスを受けるだけじゃなくて
お互いに支えるようなコミュニティが
もう一回創造できるかもしれないわけです
最後に大事なのはインターフェイスですね
つまりこういうシステムが
いいシステムが出来上がっても
最後はやっぱり高齢者が使えなきゃいけない
それを誰がやるんだ と
例えば コンビニってありますね
コンビニの店員さんとか
もしくは宅配で持ってきてくれる人とか
こういう人たちっていうのは地域地域で
高齢者ともうコネクションができているわけです
人間的な関係ができている
では例えば こういう人たちがサービスを届けるときに
「今日はどうなんですか？」
もしくは「今の気分はどうなんですか？」
そういうような簡単な質問をするようなことって
できますよね
実際に我々はこれをプロジェクトとして
開始しています
もしくは
皆さんのおじいちゃんとかおばあちゃんのお家に行くと
大きなテレビって多分あって
大音響で 聞いたり見たりしているじゃないですか
テレビっていうのは高齢者の人にとって
実はすごく大きな存在ですよね
大体どの家にもある
そしてそれが社会への窓口の
大きなものであるわけです
例えば テレビに話しかけたら
オペレーターみたいな人が出てきて
必要なサービスを伝えられる
もしくは必要な情報をくれる
そんなようなことも できるわけですね
既存にあるものが 新しいインターフェイスに進化する
こういうこともできるわけです
私はこういったことを考えると
すごいわくわくするんです
つまり今のITの新しい技術
そしてiPhoneに代表されるような
ああいうコンセプト
そして昔はなかったようなコンビニみたいな
社会の新しいインフラ
こういうものを組み合わせることによって
高齢者が必要なサービスをもらえて
そして誰かと繋がって
そして生きがいを感じる
こんなような社会を作ることが
できるんですよね
私はそう考えると
高齢社会ってなんとなく
暗いようなイメージになるじゃないですか
でも違うんですね
ここはイノベーションを生み出せる場なんです
自分はこのテーマに命をかけて取り組んでいる
本当に「これはいいテーマだなあ」と
自分では思っているんです
最後に皆さんにお願いしたいのは
「じゃあこれをどうやって実現していくんだ」
と考えたときには
やっぱりクラウドソーシングの考えなんです
つまり様々な人たちが
自分たちの持っているリソースを集めて
そしてプロジェクトにして進めていく
このコンセプトを使えば
ここにいる皆さん全員が
この高齢社会に対してのソリューションを作る
貢献ができるわけですね
だから今日から始めていただきたいのは
まず自分のおじいちゃんやおばあちゃん
もしくはお父さんやお母さん
もしくは近くにいるおじいちゃんおばあちゃん
その人たちを
よく見て よくお話をして
「何がこの人一番困っているんだ？」
もしくは「なんでこの人は
喜びを感じることができるんだろう？」
そういったものをよく見て 知って欲しいんです
そして皆さんひとりひとりが持っている
技術やスキルを使いながら
アイディアを出して欲しい
私はそういったアイディアと一緒に
高齢者が幸せに生きることのできる
高齢社会
こういったものを一緒に作っていきたいと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）